Let us now consider a third method for
adapting cases.
This method uses heuristics
expressed in the form of rules.
A heuristic is a rule of thumb.
Let's take an example.
Imagine that you went to a new city, and
you wanted to find out
where the downtown was.
How could you do that?
A simple heuristic is that
you just look around and
you find where
the tallest buildings are.
At least in North America, the tallest
buildings tend to be in the center,
in the downtown of the city.
And this heuristic doesn't
work all the time.
Outside North America,
this heuristic sometimes fails.
And that's the point.
A heuristic is a rule of thumb
that works often, but not always.
To see how the heuristic
method works for
adapting cases, consider our problem.
Imagine that we're at a restaurant and
we need to go back home.
Recall that we just found a solution for
going from the home to the restaurant.
Having found that solution,
having evaluated it and
executed it,
we stored it as a case in memory.
So now when we have to go back
from the restaurant to the home,
we can retrieve that previous case of
going from home to the restaurant.
Given a new problem and
a case, how do we adapt the case
to achieve the new problem?
In this case, we may have a heuristic
which says that to go back
from where you came originally, you
simple have to flip back all the terms.
This might give us a solution
that is shown here.
Note that this heuristic
may not always work.
It's a rule of thumb.
It works often, but of course,
we know that we cannot reverse
all the turns all the time.
>> So to return to our programming
example, we were doing file input, and
file input is often a very
resource intensive process.
So let's say I'm designing
a new program and for
this new program,
efficiency is a much bigger concern.
I might have a rule that says when doing
file input, it's more efficient to read
entire arrays of data at a time instead
of just reading one byte at a time.
The previous case that I'm adapting
might have had file input as 1 byte
at a time.
But I'm going to use that rule to
adapt the case to read arrays of
data at a time.
So, in that way,
that rule has helped me design a file
input method that's more efficient.
>> David,
to generalize on your answer to design.
>> Designers often use heuristics
of the kind that you mentioned.
For example,
if you want to make an artifact lighter,
try a different material.
It's a heuristic expressed as a rule.